what up guys it is Tuesday and welcome
to the gray area with myself Sarah
Garvey and the woman who stole one of
Putin's nuclear bombs so she could just
bomb the internet and explode it's just
funny things yay yay
right I didn't mean to steal it I just
it just happened you just happened bro
yeah so it just happened I didn't mean
to
um yeah we got a good show for you today
um however oh no before we get started
tell them if you have watched
two or more of our videos yup and they
have not subscribed they haven't then we
have what pal beef what do we have beef
exactly so you better get doing that
right now over to you pal okay guys a
couple announcements the first being is
that we have two new clips channels the
first being just Pearl eclipse and the
second being Pearl daily go subscribe to
both are in the description we have two
different editors that work on these
accounts so you get you know a little
bit different um stuff with the clips
thank you guys for getting us to 70k I'm
the one
um and the second one is roughly 15K and
and I think we're gonna hit 400k this
stream if you guys actually hit the
subscribe
honestly
um it has been so cool because I think
we've hit gotten 100K Subs every month
the past like three four months so it's
crazy it's actually mad how how quickly
we've been growing it's all thanks to
you guys why are you laughing no I'm in
shock that's why yeah we were just doing
the 250k live stream like two months ago
what should we do at 500k Jazz last time
I said something you almost chopped my
head off so I'm gonna let you choose was
there like an ice bucket challenge or
something no no I said there's a 500K
live stream I don't know what should we
do for 500k whatever you want to do what
do you want to do you know what I want I
think Super Chat should decide what
you're going to do yeah
highest Super Chat gets to decide what
we do for 500k no weird [ __ ] you know
what I mean yeah no witch
500 is the cap
um okay guys so first we have as you
know we have four membership tiers the
first membership Target lets you be a
part of the chat second membership tier
you get to see her behind in the scenes
Vlogs and be a part of our Discord
Community we're putting a lot of time
and effort into Discord in the next
month so make sure you're part of that
I'm learning how to use it so you'll get
me in the chat third tier is you connect
with us on social media and fourth
fourth tier is a one-on-one call with me
once a month um a lot of people use this
for YouTube help or other things so
subscribe to or sign up for that on top
of that go follow my Instagram
um there have been some whales on my
page that have gotten me to 50K
so that's just dot pearly things just
dot pearly things also my Tick Tock is
just pearly things.4 and just pearly
things dot five we just got to 150k in a
month because we took away my first
three accounts and it doesn't even
matter because you guys just build the
next one even faster
yeah they can't get rid of me they can't
take me off the internet
um on top of it actually owns the
internet look at they can't they tried
they took away my first second and third
account number four you guys did it
um okay also we're gonna have a members
only live stream and yeah that's all my
announcements so we have we have some
guests and we are going to be discussing
the attack on masculinity today
um but before we even get started um we
can all go around and can you tell us
your name your age relationship status
and a fun fact about you
I hate the fun fact question yeah it
could just be a stat that you know okay
okay so so well I am Troy Francis I'm a
dating coach and a YouTuber and a
digital content creator
and uh what's the next bit uh I'm 47
years old and a fun fact about me is
when I was at school right we had to do
this uh contest where we would um
everyone went underwater the swimming
lesson everyone go underwater and hold
their breath and I was able to hold my
breath longer than anyone else
I can't remember how long but it was
quite 12 seconds 12 seconds yeah yeah it
was longer than anyone else that's all
we need to know so I don't know take
from that what you will
hello guys my name is Nina but people
call me nonye I'm a YouTuber content
creator I'm 22 years old and fun fact I
don't really have anything fun like my
one is a bit cringe though my party
trick is I guess like I can go like this
I don't know what else to say
I mean
um hello everyone my name is Reuben 33
um I'm a filmmaker and so I work in
television and film production
fun fact
I don't really know what a fun fact
would look like for me but
um I'll just give you I have a son
that's 10 years old I'll just give you
that
nice
all right hey everybody
um I am Jess and I'm 28 years old and a
oh I'm single fun fact is that if you um
take all the Great Lakes of Michigan it
spells out home
oh no oh how uh here on Ontario uh
Michigan
Erie and Superior homes those homes okay
now I know that yeah thanks for the
information you're welcome so
um ladies and gents um we are going to
play you a video
um we're talking about the attack on
masculinity
does anybody here know who Candice Owens
is or is not my whatever yes okay good
um we're gonna listen to her speak and
then we're gonna discuss what she said
so uh blessing yeah play the clip please
my friend
foreign
because that's what they learned online
and a bunch of celebrities got in line
and said that's great the trans agenda
what's worse these celebrities that are
advocating for the harm of our children
through all of these various means or a
guy that's a part of a manosphere that's
clearly playing apart
I'll also say this why do these people
get so many followers why does Andrew
Tate get so many followers why does Dan
Bilzerian why do Dave portno and now
these people are different but why do
they Inspire so many men to want to get
behind them well maybe it's because we
are living in a society that keeps
trying to force the Other Extreme
these men are hungry for leadership they
want to be told that it's okay to be a
man right because everything around them
look at the media oh toxic masculinity
oh you're a bad person if you don't have
your tail between your legs oh the woman
should act like men and the men should
act like women right men should
apologize for being men that is the
message that is coming from the
mainstream media and so of course these
men are looking for something else give
me anything else give me somebody that
at least says it's okay to be a man and
these men do it they say it's cool I
like hot chicks and guys go yeah awesome
at least we said it stop trying to tell
men they have to like fat people right
you have to like lizzo if you don't
think that lizzo is hot sauce then
you're problematic right that's the
message that they're getting so then
someone gets in the platform and they
say water is wet they say hot chicks are
hot and these men celebrate as they
should because they need to stop hearing
these ridiculously toxic ideas and stop
being led to believe that there's no
place for them in our society
I'll wrap this portion by saying this
there is no society that can survive
without strong men so this is the
natural response to a society that is
impressing upon male weakness you're
going to get the other extreme
why are you so thank you blessing
ladies and gents
what did we think of that clip do you
think there is an attack on masculinity
and are men looking for leadership
you guys weigh in when you want
um
I would say that there's an attack on
truth
and I think men favor truth as opposed
to opinion so it's not necessarily
attack on masculinity it's attack on
truth and because you're attacking truth
you're leaning towards the side of men
um
so yeah that's what I would say is more
of so like she said like give an example
of like lizard or like finding hot
chicks men know like oh [ __ ] so if you
try to convince me to find this
attractive or whatever it may be you
were like no
well if you told so if you if you give
me the truth man will just just go lean
towards that side that's what I think
it's more of
so yeah okay
you said you agree with what he said I
just feel like I agree with you saying
that they
agree with truth but
she threw me off with the lizzo and the
um what other statement did she say with
the heart that you know she threw me off
with the lizard statement because I just
feel like in society today obviously as
being a big girl myself I just feel like
is your opinion if you like big girls or
not and it doesn't matter if you don't
like big girls is your opinion at the
end of the day and I do feel like
Society is trying to stretch it to say
oh if you don't like big people you're
problematic but it's just it's just down
to preference at the end of the day and
that's just how I feel so just me being
a big girl like I don't really care if a
guy says he doesn't like big girls okay
that's your opinion I don't like big
guys I mean why why do you feel like
you're So based with that because that's
not common what do you mean like a lot
of girls that are bigger like they get
offended I don't get offended and and I
don't either like if a guy said I don't
like tall gingers I'd be like okay yeah
I just feel like society today we're all
like about be kind we're all about like
pro pro big girls with about Pro like
just a lot of things that is just if
it's an opinion as an opinion but we're
just pushing it way too much to the
point where she's set an example of
um Andrew Tate because I've watched his
Clips like promoting leadership but at
the end of the day I'm cultured as well
to be honest so I feel like a man should
be a leader it shouldn't be an issue but
maybe the way he's expressing it is just
a problem I mean it's not really like
you being a leader you can be a leader
the facts he's just saying a bit too
much maybe that's why this may be like
the internet today is getting offended
by it the way he speaks about it you
know oh no me personally I don't get
offended by anything like I know how I
am and that's just how it is what do you
think Troy attack on masculinity I think
it's become increasingly difficult to
talk about certain things relating to
masculinity I mean I work as a primarily
as a dating coach we we teach guys how
to you know become better in the dating
Marketplace we actually work with guys
in real life and um do stuff obviously
online you know over zoom and stuff like
that as well but actually working with
guys in the in the field
getting them into social interactions
watching what they do critiquing what
they do giving them giving them tips on
how to you know how to improve and so on
and
um I've often felt that being a dating
coach in 2022 going into 2023 is one of
the most despised jobs in the entire
world because you get Flack from from
what she's talking about you get flagged
from the sort of mainstream because they
will think you're misogynistic for some
reason or they'll think that you you
hate women or you're being sort of
manipulative which isn't true you'll
also get Flack from the sort of the
traditionalists who are more like well
you know you just want to just bet all
these different women and you're not
about a serious serious relationship
stuff like that and that's not true
either necessarily because he's down to
the individual what they want to do
um so so yeah I think we have got to a
place now where
it's very hard to say anything yeah
because of this culture of everybody
being offended by everything and I think
that's so yeah I think in that and and
you know
feminists would argue well be to redress
the balance from things in the past now
you know we're now sort of men are now
under a lot more scrutiny than they once
were but it seems to me the pendulum has
swung too far in the sense that now we
can't really have a sort of an even
honest conversation about the way things
actually are you know and I don't even
really think that the pendulum was
necessarily for women throughout all of
history because we didn't even have to
fight in worse no we never had to do
that yeah yeah no I know what I was
saying that I was thinking I know you're
you know because I'm not saying that was
necessarily true but I'm just saying
that's what the percentage you know I'm
agreeing with you yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what that's what the perception
was wasn't it and why why do you think
um
because it's interesting because I was
telling you before the show like I've
been to like a like a dating coach type
conference before and I really didn't
see the big deal like why people were so
mad about it because I'm like if guys
don't know how to talk to women like
isn't it good that we like learn that
they learn we want guys that know how to
talk to us right yeah well you would you
would think so wouldn't you and I've
never really understood the sort of the
height and then and then you get paid
from other people like the Dumas who say
well it's all about look so if you're
not six foot seven and you know you've
got a 12-pack and all the rest of it
then you haven't got a chance anyway so
it's all it's all nonsense
um yeah you would think that wouldn't
you because actually all we're doing
really a lot of this stuff it really
goes back to old-fashioned social skills
and old-fashioned confidence skills and
a lot of guys you know people watching
this they might think well this this
game stuff you know this dating advice
stuff it's been around for ages we all
know all this but there's a lot of guys
out there who really really need help
you know they're just really not very
socially Adept and and that's probably
the majority of men yeah I would say you
think so well I think I think the
majority men are kind of maladapted to
you know social situations sexual
situations relationship situations we
can we we cite the stat you know one in
three men you know for the whole year
has not had sex or yeah a virgin right
so you have to understand that a lot of
a lot of men the average man is not
socially adapted to yeah you know
interacting with women generally yeah
yeah for sure and it's only got worse
because of the prevailing culture where
now
I mean I've heard some terrible stories
about you you know I'm glad I'm not 18
anymore going into this dating Market
because you know it's like what can you
say what can you not say are you gonna
get accused of some you know some
terrible crime because you asked out the
wrong girl I mean it's it's very long
time yes you said the wrong thing
exactly exactly so it's very fraught
with difficulty now and that's the whole
thing about mass for me the attack on
masculinity because
masculine men are quite
they're Hunters I would say right yeah
and when masculine men see a woman that
they like they normally go for it yeah
now that woman I think in the in these
days and times has been kind of
pre-programmed with he shouldn't say
this he shouldn't say that he's not
allowed to make you feel this
uncomfortable right yeah but masculine
men just go for what they go for and
they say what they say but that is now
um a thing where now you know a lot of
women can say oh I felt uncomfortable
and I was actually harassed or you know
so I think Master when I say the attack
there's a girl in the show that said
that she was
um sexually harassed like something she
I forgot what she said she was sexually
assaulted or harassed something like
that yeah and a persistent or something
yeah because some guy was like cat
calling her and like was being
persistent with it I saw that I'm like
are you you're scarred by that God yeah
by being catcalled if that's the worst
thing that's ever happened to you you've
been having a very privileged wife
because because a man called You
Beautiful more than once yeah yeah
but that's the thing I kind of like
there's a whole group of homeless people
that I walk by here every day
hey you look pretty I was like thank you
one day you're gonna be 60 and No One's
Gonna Be complicated
and then you see those articles sorry
then you see those articles don't you
where you've got the the female
journalist who is now over the age of
like so you're 40 or whatever and she's
like oh the guys aren't looking at me
anymore and I'm finding it hard to
adjust to this new reality where I'm
invisible it's like well which did you
want you know well that's the thing I
think sorry go on no I was gonna say I
understand what you're saying is an
attack on masculinity and the reason why
I say it's an attack on Truth more than
masculinity is because when
these group of people attack masculinity
they tend to attack femininity as well
and they put it in a position where it's
they're trying to make feminine women
more masculine so I feel like they're
attacking both sides with lies so for
example in the case of like oh when you
get to making women feel like oh when
you thought you're going to be desirable
and all of this kind of thing that's
just not the truth like okay it works
for some people so they're attacking the
truth more
and we if you if he align with the truth
more you you tend to be like I I
generally believe men align with facts
more like less of their feelings more
facts no because when women speak they
say I feel like and that's obviously a
fact
no but I I agree because like the reason
why I was just being physician just
because the show that's what we hear all
the time like I feel like right but
when you say there is an attack on
femininity also so I agree that the
society in which we live in is
attempting to effeminize men and then
masculine lives women right and so I
think that's one of the major reasons
why so many podcast shows are the way
they are talking about relationships
because I think that men and women have
lost their role so yeah while I would
say there is an attack on masculinity
yes right I think there's an attack on
femininity also trying to make them more
masculine yeah I would second that I
remember
um
it was a clip of Bishop TD Jakes from
the states he said like in his church
um that women need to stop asking acting
so masculine and start being feminine I
saw it and I was like I'm surprised he's
saying that in the church but there was
so much backlash from it I'm like if
y'all just shut up and listen to what
he's saying like it's uh huh the women
shopping list everybody but more so
women that's a question though yeah what
do you guys mean by them being less
masculine though because I thought no
women like we should stop being more
like less masculine or whatever because
I just feel like they're talking about
independence like I mean like we're more
able to do our own stuff without the
men's yeah but men don't want that they
want to be needed like when you say I
don't need a man like the guys want to
run but that's not really that's not
that to me that's not really a masculine
I would you wouldn't say like
Independence yeah yeah I would say that
that's masculine
like feminine feminine like throughout
all of history we needed Ben right we
still need men we just don't admit it
like men built the world for us we
couldn't we couldn't survive without
without them they do the plumbing the
the sewers the garbage collectors they
build the buildings engineering they do
all of the hard jobs in society and so
women pretend we don't need them but we
literally couldn't survive without them
being able to be a single woman on your
own is such a privilege that we women
have never gotten in all of society and
you know why and how we thank them is we
[ __ ] on the men that did it for us and
the only reason why you can be a single
woman who is actually safe is because of
men
yeah because police officers you know
firemen you know all the people that
were going to protect you are going to
be men I need to say something go for it
bro
if I call the cops and they send me a
woman
especially here especially here because
you guys don't have guns here right what
is she gonna do
I wish I'm probably taller than her you
know what if it's like a Helga woman
when I see security
average guy okay look at we play
basketball okay and you know damn well
that an average guy that's not muscular
that's like skinny can still beat us and
we're in shape yeah
and I'm like wait what on Earth is a
woman gonna do to help me so so that
being said though pal so you're pretty
red poo and you're pretty based anyway
but what is it that makes women who
actually know this because you just said
when I say a woman security guard I'm
like right what is it that makes women
try to to go against the the nature that
we already know that when men say men
are masculine we're stronger we don't
know this what is a pushback why do
women always push back against that
I can't talk for women I just feel like
I just feel like
is being pushed a lot saying that oh we
need to stop being masculine but it's
just based on just Independence like
let's say worst case scenario single
moms they do everything by themselves I
mean but I do understand where you guys
are coming from like there are roles
based for men period like plumbers I
actually get that but it's like I feel
like in society today women can do that
too but it's not maybe to the extent of
a man can do it as efficient as sharp as
more practical I mean we're definitely
gonna maybe ask for help a little extra
help from somebody doesn't actually
necessarily I think yeah I think the
point is that if all if all men
disappeared tomorrow women would be
screwed Wherever not screwed
hahaha
depending on what you identify as a
woman oh well exactly
I think I can answer your question and
why women
do that I think it's because what men do
we can put value on it a monetary value
on it and women's natural skills is hard
to monetize it in terms of so if you're
a woman and you're caring and you're
feminine and you're affectionate it's
hard to put a price price on that and
you can't sell something that you can't
really put a price on and I feel like
because we understand the value of money
and obviously if we can say oh a man can
do this and this is worth this amount we
evaluate more as opposed to a woman who
can take care of a home and take care of
the children we're like well how much is
that actually worth
do you go and say so people are
naturally going to assume because you
can put a price on whatever men do it
might be more valuable as opposed to
what a woman can do which is equally as
valuable and different but we just don't
know how to put a price on it because if
you say for example um teachers or
Nursery nurse they don't necessarily get
paid a lot even though their job is
extremely valuable do you understand but
didn't there used to be a time where men
saw women as Priceless anyway and what
they've done is priceless
I think it's because women are less
valuable nowadays
yeah because we're we're not pure are
there like women aren't virgins anymore
and we're older than ever when we get
married the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31. how many
bodies does a girl got by 31.
and so like like they might have
worshiped the ground the women from the
1950s walked on but those women had
cookbooks they were mothers they were
wives like half of our generation wasn't
even raised by wives how the hell would
they know how to be one exactly so
that's what I said like back in the days
you would think of a woman as Priceless
yeah you can't actually put a price on
what they do because it in theory it's
Priceless as opposed to a man there is a
price for your your skill set your value
and all of this kind of thing however I
think it's like what do you call it um
marketing that's got people confused to
think like because you could put a price
on something that it's valuable and but
most things you that aren't um that are
Priceless are the most things that hold
value to you do you understand if that
makes sense so going back to the video
Candace Owen said um that no Society can
kind of survive
without strong men absolutely not
um however this Society seems to be
telling men that they can be women
right and
um literally literally women and so if
we live in a society now that as
everybody knows because what she said to
me isn't that controversial because we
know that Society should survive with
strong men so if our society Western
Society is now telling men there can be
women what do you think the future for
the society is going to be Jesus has
that every civilization that was like
female-led crashed
yeah
sorry gone I was thinking about
something like this sort of recently and
the reason why I was thinking about it
is because I saw a school student
walking around with a bonnet on his head
and I've seen this quite frequently like
young kids very important young male
boys men yeah men wearing bonnets on
their head just casually and I thought
this is so interesting I feel like
what's gonna happen maybe not for Our
Generation but the next generation of
young people kids or whatever
I think the women are actually going to
be attracted to feminine men I said well
okay well you say you said this and
you've got the um of course you've got
the K-pop phenomenon haven't you yeah
androgynous type of a man yeah yeah
exactly so that is that's that's
definitely possible but is that really
what they're viscerally going to desire
I mean maybe it is but I think it's
already happening I have no I have I
don't I don't know if it was you that
told me this but someone I was on an
Instagram live a couple months ago and
they were talking about
would you date a guy that had like done
stuff with like another guy in the past
yeah and I was like no like nesky not a
never and or like a like bot like they
were a guy that was bi and they said the
younger generation doesn't care and he's
like call your sister and I was like no
way she'll say yes like no way so I call
her and I'm like like Eva Amelia my two
younger sisters like would you date a
guy that's bi and they were both like
Yeah well yeah you know I was I mean
they're young like um my one sister is
19. oh and my other sister us
no why not that's why I'm intrigued no
that's why because to me it was like a
quick ew no and my my other sister
that's 21 22. I have nine siblings I
forget but but she said no but there
seemed to be a cut off with like the
youngest too because that's the thing
like like you were just saying I've said
it on the show uh a couple of times that
women are now being attracted to
feminine men because they're becoming
more masculine the more feminine the guy
because you know essentially Opposites
Attract and like you were saying um
about the the cave pop phenomenon yeah
where men are looking less like men and
more like Harry Styles Harry Styles yeah
right
um men are starting to look less like
men and more kind of morphing into like
man woman knee type yeah I don't know
androgynous type men and so that's what
women are becoming attracted to
a lot of women are all but a lot of
women are becoming attractive yeah but
don't you don't you think in some ways
though the sort of the raw masculine
archetype still wins through because if
you look if you if you read a lot of the
sort of like the the online advice
that's directed at man it's all very
much I mean what is everyone bang on
about the whole time it's all it's all
lifting lift you know lift lift 15 times
a day and stuff
um and and it's all geared towards
becoming that ape that sort of so-called
Apex Alpha type guy and I think
ultimately that that still cuts through
because if you take it to a slightly
lesser extreme not necessarily about
people who are androgynous because
that's that's one thing but what about
the sort of man boobed sort of chest
feeling Millennium sort of dude who's
got the sort of hipster beard and oh and
carries a tote bag you know that kind of
guy right he's sort of like he's not
feminine as such but he's also not sort
of archetypally mass you know the edges
have been softened haven't they right
yeah yeah Society so I think then if
you're like an Andrew Tate type
character you know you kind of cut
through all that all that BS and you
sort of still making however I feel like
this is a this is one of the first times
in history that the weak have governed
the strong well yeah yeah like the tech
overlords right so like so these guys
generally are like the weaklings but
they were intelligent right and normally
we lived in a society where Alpha men
would take over like Nations right with
armies and stuff but it's no longer that
the the the the the Revolution and the
Takeover is now in an intellectual one
yeah a lot of the time strength doesn't
it doesn't matter in that situation what
matters is how how much you can
out-think the opponent and so a lot of
the time now in these in these days and
times the the week and our governing the
strong because and I say that on on
another front where if your feelings get
hurt for instance we can now cancel you
and we can now make new laws to make our
feelings not get hurt so the weak are
now governing the strong so the strong
say things like Andrew Tate like Kevin
Samuels to
um you know to cut through the the
nonsense like you said but if somebody's
feelings get hurt you understand who's
really in power
well yeah and you've just got to look at
what happened obviously with with the
tights although you know obviously I'm
sure he'll be he'll be fine he'll be
fine but you know it's a very
interesting example isn't it of how
everybody just sort of like they just
all of his socials just went down like
dominoes because of feelings yeah and
that's the thing and even when I was at
carnival like the the visceral reaction
I got from women like interviewing them
and I said what do you think of Andrew
Tate and they're immediately like and
I'm like what does he say that's that
bad yeah like okay men don't like old
women like who cares I don't think it's
anything he says that is bad it's kind
of like um with
um Kevin Samuels how he when I first
before I first watched his videos I'd be
like oh Kevin blah blah blah bad things
about black women blah blah blah when I
watched I was like he's actually okay
the truth and so I think when it comes
to women and
when it comes to women and
not just women but mainly in this
conversation when something is brought
against them they don't take the time to
listen and look into what it is this
person is saying is instantly like you
said something against women we're going
to try to get you off as quickly as
possible instead of sitting down
listening to what he's saying taking the
bits that are like okay maybe that's
true and other bits be like Ah that's
not true and taking it in me and being
like how can I better myself from this
conversation that this man had even
though his approach may not be something
that I like to hear but what his words
are saying is something that I may need
to hear that's what it is I feel like
women
feel a lot more by the way men say
things but going down to the factual
things we don't really take it in as you
said like it's just based on as you said
one word and we're just like no that was
rude but it's just like you have to take
it in a bit more but it depends on
maturity but that's why I said the week
the week now governed the strong because
only the weak yet yeah you know I mean
their feelings get hurt and then they
govern the strong and they say oh you're
not allowed to say that now now there's
no more strong people because the wheat
got offended yeah all we were talking
about this the other the other day or
that fresh and fit show and I was the
it came up like what did he actually get
canceled for and I can't even I mean
maybe somebody can answer but I can't
think specifically what he got canceled
for really it was just he got canceled
just for being Andrew Tate really and
like one you know social media company
banned him then the next one and then
they're probably sitting there in their
boardroom thinking oh God we've got to
do something about this guy and then so
the next one goes down and it was like
that wasn't it it wasn't I don't think
it was like a specific like you know
there was a certain sentence or yeah
I don't think there was anything
specific that he got canceled for
um zubi was a guess and I think he was a
flying a little bit too close to the Sun
in some subject areas and exposing
certain areas of the world and they were
like gotta cut them off yeah yeah yeah
you know I only came into
um aware of Andrew tape because he was
getting banned obviously I've seen him
around
um on the internet but I never really
paid attention to it yeah until people
started oh this guy's got banana then I
started looking into it and I'm like
listening to some of the things he's
saying I was like like he said I
couldn't quite pinpoint yeah what it was
but then then if you dig a deeper
they'll be like oh he's a
um he's like sex trafficking he's a sex
trafficker and things like that and I'm
one of those people I take what people
say on the internet with a Pinter so
especially if a collective of people are
saying it together but then you hear him
explain it and then he's like I've never
been arrested for it oh there's no
charges for it and things of this nature
then I started to realize that you're
not actually giving real evidence to why
you want to ban them like you said just
because do you think his masculinity is
the thing that's that's that scared
people well maybe but just to play
devil's advocate here for a second is
this actually an attack on masculinity
using him as an example but you know we
can broad broaden it out or is it just
basically all these companies want to
make money and they're all protecting
their bottom line and they're protecting
their bottom line because they're like
oh if we if people are getting offended
because we're allowing this dude to be
on our Channel then we're going to lose
money we're going to lose subscribers
we're gonna lose our Revenue whatever
so it's not from the Takeover Lord's
point of view it may not necessarily be
some so much like oh he's toxically
masculine and I hate that that stuff it
it could it just be like oh damn we
don't want to lose cash so let's be
careful do you see what I'm saying I
could I do I I think it may be both to
some degree and I think
um that may be a byproduct of the attack
on masculinity if that makes sense so
yeah so getting rid of him is a
byproduct of there being an attack on
masculinity because it's like he's too
masculine people are getting offended so
let's so let's get rid of him so for me
I feel like you know
um if you look at masculinity within
what we're sold in the media you know
when it comes to fatherhood and if you
look at the Simpsons you look at Family
Guy you look at all of these shows this
the fathers and the men in there are
bumbling idiots yes you know what I mean
and so when we get sold what masculinity
is we get sold it to us like men are
kind of stupid and yeah women are the
Smart Ones you know yeah and so adverts
as well are really bad for that if you
watch TV adverts like supermarkets and
DIY stores and stuff like that it's
always the stupid stupid husband you
know dumb husband yeah yeah yeah do you
think if Andrew Tate was a woman he used
to be on the internet oh yeah for sure I
mean well we'll see they call me Andrea
Kate
I don't think they took away my Tick
Tock though so maybe not but if
something if a woman was delivering in
the same tone Andrew Tate would take
delivering it do you think she would get
um taken off I don't I don't think so no
I don't know I think I think there's a
double it'll be interesting to see I
think so because like I said I keep I
think I genuinely believe is an attack
on Truth more than masculinity I didn't
and I just that's why I would like to
see if there's a woman who delivers it
the same way as Andrew Tate I tell you
why not I tell you I don't think so the
other day
um literally last week I watched a video
of a female male rapper
with a song called Murder on my mind and
she was talking about aborting her child
and the whole song was about how she's
going down to Planned Parenthood and
she's forgotten to take her plan B and
she's got murder on her mind and she's
gonna take and she's gonna get rid of
her child and that was trending on yeah
exactly on the internet she never got
canceled and so if you can be that
vulgar as a woman and you can be that to
in my personal point of view crazy
and that let's say I don't know it's not
misogyny it's not misandrist but it's
really anti-child and anti-family is she
popular though who is it
um you know we could actually search her
now you can just put murder on my mind
right with Andrew Tate is a lot more
because there's a lot more people
watching it you know if people a lot
more people are watching it they're
going to want to cancel her but you know
like if the person is not too popular no
one really knows her what about cardi B
she drugged a man she drugged him out
yeah
I wrote it quick really guys
um we just hit 400.
guys
400k 400k that's like basically half a
million yeah
biggest biggest Super Chat decides what
we do for half a million 500 the cap
yeah what we're gonna do for half a
million yeah what 24 hour live stream no
no no no no
yeah everyone here is eight hours of
that 48 Hours yeah the 24 hour live
stream was horrible that was crazy but
anyway let's get back
um if I can to be saying something no no
go on Jess no um I was just gonna say
that I think I agreeing with you that I
think that
um
attack on masculinity is also profitable
nowadays right the more the more you can
side it with
the
um
the feminist movement and talk down
about men as much as possible the more
it's popular to do nowadays and you just
said oh what the the female rapper even
if she was big and out there
I don't think she would I don't think
she would get canceled at all because
that's something that
it's liberating for women to have the
opportunity now that it's different in
the states the laws are different in the
states for abortion it's like oh yeah
you have the freedom to go do that now
so I don't think that she would ever
even if she was a big well-known artist
I don't think she would get canceled
because of that
um do you guys have an idea if we go
around what I'm gonna ask what is a
masculine man to you I was gonna ask you
guys that you know well it's a masculine
man
as a man I think it's somebody who lives
by their own rules and doesn't
necessarily accept the dictates of
society easily
um and is his own mental point of origin
to quote um roller tomasi
there are certain other things as well I
mean some physical prowess you know
physical fitness ability to uh maybe
some fighting training things like that
you know go go towards that archetypal
sort of masculine guy but I think
fundamentally what it comes down to is
being on your own path and not being
cowed by
Society exactly and and what others want
you to be and do and I think what we're
seeing now is a lot of people who a lot
of guys who actually are being killed by
society and they're going along with the
narrative or they feel the narrative to
be
I would say the same thing to be fair I
feel like a guy is just more practical
more able to give to let's say for a
female
um they have to have an ounce of like
gym in them or like doing something
masculine in society and just
intelligent I would say and obviously in
their own path like they don't really
listen to outside they're not really a
social Conformity did you sorry I'll go
around and ask a question
um I would say someone who is extremely
confident in the on purpose someone who
understands
um
the the goal is the
the objectives is more important than
you are so you're willing to sacrifice
for the most time most of the time it
will be you for the purpose of the of
the aim or the goal of whatever you're
doing so it would be your family if you
be your country it could be your
community you are so if you're willing
to put your Yourself In Harm's Way or
for your community something like that
yeah
what's a masculine man someone who is
not feminine
I agree with everybody and I want to add
on to it someone who's a leader
um I think that's a very masculine trait
and people argue women can be leader
um not as well as men I would say and it
all boils down to if a man's not leading
in the household it's it's gonna crumble
and I think a guy who's not afraid to
speak his mind right because it's like a
breath of fresh air when like a guy
walks into a room and he's just like not
I don't I don't think that's right he's
not afraid to say what he thinks right
because as women like we can feel when
you're pandering to us yeah like we just
we could like feel it in our soul or
even when you have a conversation with a
woman and they're just like yeah yeah
agreeing with you and it's like I want I
want to have that like pushback or want
to have that conversational but
but the thing is a lot of men don't
understand that that in the short in the
short term that works for a certain type
of woman so yeah you know the Derek
Jackson's of the world right and um do
you know I mean like those kind of guys
who Pander towards women it works for a
short space of time but essentially
women like masculine men you know I mean
and they respect them and so you know
I've said so many times this
um society and a lot a lot of the time
the feminist movement attempted to build
the type of man that women wouldn't want
yeah they always do that so what they've
done is that they said become more
feminine and be more in touch with your
feminine side I grew up in a time where
there was a you probably got the same
time these are called a metrosexual yeah
exactly remember that term the
metrosexual right yeah and that's like
what the hell is a Metro and that's when
women started to kind of effeminize men
and say oh men are supposed to be a
little more feminine to be in touch with
feminine side and I'm like you're
building the type of men that you
wouldn't even be attracted to why would
would you do that yeah exactly well I
drank the Kool-Aid on that a little bit
not the much sexual thing but even
slightly before that that's that phrase
um
uh get in touch with your phone and
inside it came from like the 80s maybe
something like that and I remember that
phrase being it was around in the in the
Consciousness and um you know early on I
sort of believed it for a bit I thought
our women they want to see you being
vulnerable they want now and then what
you discovered that well
baby lion
in the harsh in the harsh gladiatorial
ring of dating is that if you show that
sort of vulnerability and weakness
um you'll you're gonna get kicked to the
curb right particularly early on I mean
maybe you get a bit more leeway if
you've been in a you know long-term
relationship but but even then you know
you've got to retain that masculine core
otherwise really your toast I have a
question for the girls okay he's a one
to ten he's a five but he's really
masculine what is he how many points
does that give a guy
she's a six but she's like super
feminine what is she she's my wife
it probably would actually give her
additional points because because people
think oh you know guys it's all about
looks blah blah blah obviously there's a
degree of Truth in that because we are
very you know physical you know look at
us just start somewhere yeah exactly but
same for women oh yeah you know when
you're traveling around and you meet
women who have very they are very
feminine and they are very pleasant and
and all that it definitely adds
something to it for sure oh definitely
yeah
oh sorry sorry go on I have a question
for the men
what like is that do you like your women
like submissive like she's not
independent because the way you said
nine it seems as if like you don't want
your your babe to do anything kind of
thing you know what I mean for me I'll
be honest like like he said he kind of
drank the Kool-Aid of the
yeah growing up I I like to think I was
relatively I'm very independent thinking
I just do what I wouldn't even say I'm
necessarily masculine one woman
described it to me um what's the word
I can't remember she's a word and I
never heard of it and I researched it
and I'm like oh really this described me
it's when you're independent thinking
you don't really care like a sigma type
that's is it Sigma yes Sigma male is
something better she said something like
that I never heard of that term before
when I research I'm like yeah this is
kind of me I just do whatever I want I
don't really care what people are saying
anyway
in doing that I go with a girl that I
liked and I pandered to her and I
thought you know what I'm gonna be a
nice guy I don't actually are horrible
and that just backfired in my like and
it didn't make no sense to me because I
was like I actually tried to be a nice
human being and she didn't like it and
she was but anyway so she keep listening
to women don't listen to them don't
listen to them 100 do not listen to them
but going on to what you're saying in
terms of a woman is not if she's
feminine it's not that she submissive in
the way I think you're thinking of it is
more that
I look at it like less stress I just
look at it as like less stress so that
means like I'm not a horrible human
being so I'm not going to take advantage
of you and take the myth out of you but
if you are comfortable in your
femininity it just makes me want to do
more for you like it's such I always use
this as an example if you go back to um
when you was in school there's always
like a group of girls who are very loud
and very boisterous and very present
themselves to be masculine and they'll
always be a group of girls who are quite
bad girls are masculine yes yeah yeah
and there'll be a group of girls who are
quiet I always said if there was a fight
to ever happen I'm protecting the girls
who are quiet right just naturally
because I just feel like I have to
protect you because you're always louder
than all of this kind of thing I'm like
yeah let them deal with it yeah and I'll
protect the people that are quiet just
because something about them is telling
me that they need protection and I will
naturally gravitate to them and that's
just how it works I don't know how it
just happens like if you're feminine I
just I just want to help you so so you
are so repeat your question again
um what makes a woman like so submissive
that it's just like yes like I don't
know I don't know I forgot you said you
said something along the line
um is do you really want
to them yeah like do you want her like
dependent on you completely like she has
nothing kind of thing I I think a lot of
women
um misconstrue what submission is you
know I mean I think when you say that
the fact that you think submission is a
woman relying solely on her man and not
having any independence of her own it
kind of um
it speaks to the psychology of what the
term submission is for a lot of people
because I don't think submission is a
woman not having her own do you know I
mean like women can have their own and I
think I think it's smart for you to have
your own yeah so um Auntie had a really
good analogy last time she was here she
was like even if a woman works like I um
oh there was like she was describing a
couple and she's like yeah she would
take her money from work and hand it to
her husband
because she's like you trust him with
your body how could you not trust him
with money like do you not think your
body is more valuable than money
so do you do you think you have a
different version of submission no
because I'm just I was just like
throwing back the way he said yes nine
so that's what I was just thinking again
I mean the the word was femininity
wasn't it as opposed to some
submissiveness so maybe that was I mean
for me submissiveness I put it into a
separate thing I mean that's that's
almost another subject matter I mean for
me because we were talking about
femininity for me that's that's really
super important I mean if she's you know
yeah of course I mean she's got to have
her own she's making her own money she's
going out she's doing her job she's got
us because because to be honest for me
personally the opposite of that is
really unattractive as well if she's
just sitting around and she's not doing
anything yeah yeah you know what you
don't want that either but it's it's so
for me it's not so much about those
things it's more about okay what's our
attitude like okay is she Pleasant to be
around is she funny she nurturing is she
you know all of those those things
um I was talking to one of my friends
the uh the other day he was telling me
that his girl is so in her femininity
that it's easy for him to be in his
masculine he can be himself because
she's not trying to essentially be a man
and be in a masculine a masculine space
or be in her masculinity masculinity she
is able to be feminine and he's able to
be masculine and just makes him feel
like I can be me and do you know how
many men and women are both waiting on
to enter their masculine and feminine
right there are women that are waiting
who are masculine women who are waiting
to be feminine I don't believe that
they're just not I don't I don't believe
that I don't I think like women when
they say they can turn it on and off
it's a cop-out and they're just not
feminine yeah like I just like someone
someone had something that said like
femininity can't be gained it can only
like you're born with a certain amount
of femininity and then you'd lose it but
but then I think a lot of men and the
reason why I say this because I think a
lot of men in these days and times are
waiting to be masculine I don't know I
don't I don't agree with that you don't
think men are waiting to be matched
I'll expanded it because the reason why
I say that is because I think men have
been told to be feminine for so long
like we're talking about I don't know
you know the metrosexual stuff
there's been a mantra that your
masculinity is bad okay and it's toxic
and you need to remove it from yourself
however it's a natural thing inside a
lot of men to do so what they so what I
think a lot of men are finding and I
think a lot of the reasons why that
Andrew Tates and the Kevin Samuels has
explode is because men are now saying
yes we can be masculine again we can be
ourselves we can look at these guys and
gain leadership and it's okay to be a
man and I think there's a lot of women
waiting to be feminine also you know I
just don't think so like I think for men
it's like different like I feel like men
are like programmed to let like I feel
like I don't put it like men are one way
and like the world tells them not to be
right and women naturally are but I just
think once a woman's too far gone it's
like there's a no coming back like I
don't think she'll ever get that like
child like like innocence or like like
the I don't know the like the natural
femininity once she's like done certain
things I just think it's gone it's
really funny as well like traveling to
you know because we spent quite a lot of
time in like Eastern Europe and play is
like that and a lot of this stuff is
really cultural by the way because
obviously we're sitting in London now
you know we've you know people are
American and so on it's it's like like
in the Anglo sphere this is what we're
really talking about when you go to some
of these other places it's less
pronounced yeah it's a bit of a cliche
because I mean Poland is now very
westernized country it's part of the EU
it's quite quite wealthy it's whatever
but
still there's a bit more polarity
between the genders still you know what
I mean like the women are very famously
very feminine you know to the fact it's
almost a bit of a cliche you know the
Polish women are very feminine there was
many sort of women from Ukraine there as
well and again very very feminine women
also exactly yeah exactly and um it's
funny because uh we were I was with uh
my friend James Tusk and uh we were in a
restaurant in Warsaw we're having a bite
to eat and at the table and we've just
been you know all these like beautiful
feminine girls around wearing their
sundresses and then on the table next to
us there was this woman from um this
this female lawyer from New York and she
was just like screeching oh my God like
the canopies were terrible you know and
all this kind of things we were just
like we just had our heads in our hands
because it was like oh we just traveled
to avoid all this stuff you know right
yeah so I think it is it's like
culturally determined but I think like
to your point
um when somebody is like that oh is I I
don't I don't I didn't feel that that
woman was sort of like just desperate to
unleash her feminine again you know what
I mean I think she she's now a a boss
babe and that's that's and that's her
Persona yeah exactly I think for the
right guy women will be feminine because
I've seen it I've seen it where there
there's been a masculine woman or she's
just very like this is me this is what
I'm gonna say and you can't tell me
different and she gets with the guy and
she's just she's sorry but you know what
I think that is is it because I think a
lot of women are playing boss babe and
they're not really I do I think a lot of
women are because they feel like that's
a person that they need to have yeah I'm
gonna get the bag and I'm gonna be a
boss that's not you so just what what
are you doing I just feel like they
could only keep that up for so long it
comes out eventually like an
argumentative woman like you're telling
me you're gonna be married 20 30 40 50
years and you're like you're never gonna
be argument like I just think like once
a woman is so far gone and if she wasn't
raised by a wife like I I think I mean I
don't want to say it's hopeless because
you know obviously like
like what else is she supposed to do
other than try yeah but I just think for
the majority like I just don't see him
going back sorry going I was gonna say
like for the women who who say this uh
for the right guy I think what they want
is just a man oh masculine them that's
too much of a battle and that is too
much of a better and when if that man
wins it can
it can almost
um tether on the line of toxicity and
that's where you get a man who has to be
extremely toxic to you tame a woman
who's masculine and I feel like that's
what they're asking for sometimes I I
I've never seen a woman who is masculine
all of a sudden because family feminine
yeah sorry go ahead yeah I've never seen
that happen so it's just like she's just
found a man that's extremely masculine
to the point where it's almost toxic and
she just has to Humble herself but it's
chaos continuously it's continuous chaos
like here somebody say that I was just
trying to think it through really I
think um I mean there's a quote I think
it was in that book mystery method you
know like one of the all the game or one
of those early words about dating and it
was ultimate ultimate masculinity
attracts ultimate femininity also
something like that and he was just
making the point that you need to
emphasize that polarity in terms of
Attraction
um so it kind of makes sense what you're
saying you know if if the the boss babe
you know suddenly this this sort of like
you know bloku looks like out of the
film Gladiator or something and you know
just just takes her up you know then
maybe she'll sort of ReDiscover her
femininity but how realistic that is in
in this day and age is is you know he's
the thing and the thing like
with the toxicity it's like also I think
guys are very conscious of their
behavior now and they're and in many
cases not every case but in many cases
they're toning it down because they're
like I've got to walk on eggshells a
little bit yeah you know what I mean so
yeah I mean there's so many interviews
I've done where the guys I know they
know the answer because I'll ask them a
question that somehow brings like an
uncomfortable truth and they know the
answer but I could see them like oh I
can't say that like I don't want to get
in trouble with work or whatever like
and so they're almost like coerced into
being feminine because like being
feminine is more like
you know not being as direct we're like
being masculine is more you know direct
yeah is it what is a toxic masculinity
and on the flip side is there any toxic
toxic femininity that was my next
question just Amber Hood
Amber Heard toxic femininity 100 I think
on either end is this an abuse of your
power so if you are a feminine woman and
you recognize your femininity you can
gain you access
um things and you use it solely for your
purpose for you to gain and go somewhere
in Life or whatever it may be to me that
can be toxic even though it may not be
so loud and things of that nature but
you feel abusing your your natural power
the same with a man if you understand
you've got a level like if you can
dominate a room and you then you're
abusing the people who who fall under
you I think I would consider that to be
toxic so I think it's like managing your
back knowing your power and managing it
if you don't do that that's when it
becomes toxic
okay
I think I think what is what classes as
toxic masculinity nowadays is not
actually toxic
[Music]
I was at an event on Sunday right and
you know we were discussing masculinity
and feminine is here and I was speaking
you guys know the way I speak I was
speaking what I speak right and some
girl in front of me turned around and
said you give me toxic vibes
yeah and secondly like what just just
expressing a
different opinion sometimes can be
called toxic and masculinity pick me
yeah you get called me I got called one
too
remember she said not you
that's because she didn't want me to
come for her
but but it's true like anything can like
be classes toxic nowadays
sorry it's just it's all very subjective
isn't it yeah it's all this thing about
like oh my feelings were hurt therefore
no it like what I've seen is when they
say toxic masculinity they mean like
traditionally masculine roles and when
they say toxic femininity like they mean
the same thing like typically like the
left more okay like so because there is
a girl that was like more left that came
on the show or like I don't know woke I
guess and she sent me a whole article on
toxic femininity and it was talking
about how traditionally feminine like
behaviors like being a housewife that
sort of thing are toxic yeah yeah look
if a man was like I just need you to
cook clean and I'll bring home the bacon
you can do whatever you want okay [ __ ] I
will do it yeah exactly I'd be like all
right but remember but that totally goes
against what you've been sold though do
you know what I mean like it totally
goes against what the whole boss [ __ ]
and the whole boss space thing is also
not the reality like yeah because
because even like when you're saying
like oh you could clean and bring up
what percent of women get to do that
like none yeah it's like maybe one in
four so like you have to still be
submissive and work yeah and most women
don't want to do that I'm not saying
full-time but like like I think only 20
of women get to be Housewives yeah and
the thing is it gets confusing for men
because it's like oh I'm independent and
I'm gonna be a boss [ __ ] but please
someone come and save me and lately be
their wife it's like what is it what is
it that you want actually like can you
guys tell us they don't know
they think they want it one way and then
once they get a taste of that I don't
like that but I can't go back what I
said they want all the benefits so they
want a guy to pay the bills yeah and
they want to do what they want and they
also want to have control over him and
they want to be treated like a queen
okay because part of the reason I got
into red pill was because my dad is the
top half a percent like dude and I was
listening to what these girls were
saying like dating a guy like him would
be like I'm like you realize my dad put
my mom to work like she had seven kids
for him like you guys think you want to
have one to two kids and if you have one
to two kids like you'll just get to sit
at home and do nothing not a nasty my
mom
my mom had to plan like all these trips
for us she had to make sure we had all
these family traditions which may sound
like oh it's nothing but she's so she
sewed her Halloween costumes for all
seven of us she she she quit her job
being a teacher to go help him build his
business she cooked for us I'm like and
you guys just think like what do you
think this is gonna be I'm like I swear
to God 90 of women do not have the work
ethic that my mom had no that to really
pull that [ __ ] off and I'm like good
good luck you you find you a guy that
you can just sit at home do nothing have
one to two kids for him and just relax
let me know how that goes for you and
he'll leave you for a younger model in
10 years can the church go to amen amen
um oh okay guys make sure you like the
video the like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams so if you think this
content is important you like it make
sure you like the video because honestly
like is free you know if you know if
you're not I see what percentage of you
hit the Subscribe button and you're not
all subscribed so if you're not going to
be subscribed at least hit the like
button okay Dustin Denton I desire to
find a woman that I can never own but
she wants her desires to be owned by me
Camden
um ravenstag the Shrew puts on a front
to convince the guy she is a good mate
um Octavius masculine man initiates
conversations and action serves protects
himself his family his community his
attainable goals and plans and is the
strongest possible male in the room when
disaster strikes congrats on 400k
norvis Knox is submissive the word or is
it respectful
okay I'm just ravenstag there is a
growing military recruiting dilemma
going on in the west a real growing
issue in Canada the US and the UK young
men are too feeble and emasculated and
women are too lazy full of themselves
our teeth have dulled marriage causes
divorce Tech Giants canceled tape before
governments complained masculine equals
power control aggressive aggressive
aggression competitive
poppy poppy puppy take-up band because
he saw through the BS of the
establishment and only by Banning him
can they keep destroying men and the
two-parent household thus giving them
total power over us Vic I don't hear
many people talking about the chemical
aspect that is changing men and women
there are studies that have shown at
adazine made frogs trans what does
adazine I don't know what that is
um
I think it I think I saw article I think
it's something that they put that
they're putting in food yeah
um Adam Sutton to Sarah's point I don't
think I don't think the weak governing
the strong is a relatively new condition
other than exceptions like Genghis Khan
intellectuals have been in charge for
easily 4 000 years Natalia grovemov
economic impact is the reason men feel
demasculated and that was done on
purpose by the feds to make us all
weaker divide and conquer NSM NSX K-pop
still exude confidence and masculine
energy only appear as pretty boys this
does not mean men like feminine women
they still have status and the bag
marriage causes divorce Society is full
of 304s and soft men who create laws so
masculinity is finished and it will not
come back mgtow will continue to grow FS
Claire to understand what's happening
look up most a Utopia experience it
ended the sexual confusion and complete
societal collapse
JH men run from when men run when women
say I don't need a man because anyone
because anyone interactions can result
in the loss of safety freedom and or
Worse Jonathan Farley I'm not a plant I
read I Jonathan Farley I'm not a I'm not
a plant I read two of Troy francis's
books before going to social events and
in one case got a date with a girl half
my age and then the other left with a
girl who appeared to be half my age look
at you
there we go okay what's your book called
it works uh I've got several I've got
one called the seven laws of Seduction
I've got another one called still in the
game I've got a bunch of them I've got
I've got a bunch of books called uh
Renegade dating blueprint actually buys
a bundle okay guys if you want if you
want to get a date with a hot hot 20
year old 25 year old 22.
um the link to his channel is in the
description
um EJ Carroll question to the man if you
had to choose between Purity and youth
which quality in a woman do you value
higher oh real quick
shhh
Purity purity
Purity Purity okay so you'd all take
um a 31 year old with how many bodies am
I gonna give her three bodies or a 20
let's do 22 year old with 22. no 31
years old thank you very much
the the UK Economist I wonder if we
entered World War III would you want an
average masculine man to protect you or
a pink haired nose ring wearing feminist
man marriage causes the voice of divorce
most guys are simps or do not want to be
canceled Simpson 304s will never stand
up for masculinity masculinity is
finished mgtow
um faza hi Pearl and Sarah have you
watched b or pbd podcast with Andrew
Tate if you do what do you think about
it if you haven't you really should do a
reaction
um to the clips on your next show
um Kenny P nice you got Troy Francis on
the red pill OG you should do a 500K
party as long as that chesca chick isn't
there
NSX road to 500k no 24-hour live streams
please a special guest or an unplanned
stream would be a nice surprise react to
Ryan long that's all of them okay uh
interesting live stream let's be fair
the last one my friend we have another
video for you guys and I just want you
guys to see this one I love this video
right and um yeah just give me your
thoughts on it bless him when you're
ready bro
see how masculine this video is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you blessing
I'm not gonna lie to you I was
entertained like I love him the the
production of the bit like it's good
good tune is that was that a takeoff of
um
a movie scene Beyonce is um as a takeoff
for Beyonce's um one of her songs I
forgot what it's called the no she's
crazy in love isn't it yeah but but
wasn't that scene from and I only know
this because my ex-girlfriend made me
watch things like Mean Girls
that's a good movie yeah I'm sure that's
I'm sure that's take anyway hasn't it
um you said you liked you liked this
what is it that you liked about that
it's the fact that um
he's portraying gay men in a feminine
way I feel like in media we don't really
get that he's one of the few that rap
for like the gay people basically and I
just find that Lit
confused over there bro you better say
something you just said he's portraying
gay men in a feminine way yeah I mean
yeah yeah that's what it is sorry that's
what it is like no but no this gay men
that are masculine I know but every time
you see gay men in the media they tend
to be feminine
um not really not well me no I see gay
men who I'm asking on the media okay
name one
um
you could name all you could name RuPaul
oh you can name him you could name
um uh what's the British uh comedian's
name
um
with the Eddie Izzard
I'm not saying they're gay but I'm just
saying a lot of people when it comes to
feminine men is what is portrayed but um
you interested you said that you liked
that or you said you like him if your
son came
if you had a child and your son said
Mommy look I want to do this what would
be your response I would like do
whatever you want
period
I just feel like in in the world today
if you want to do what you want to do if
you want to be gay be gay if you want to
be straight you can be straight right
but that what was that okay
that was gay yeah he's gay
but it's interesting no he's gay you
know what's interesting how you're like
celebrating it I'm not celebrating I
mean you thought it was like cool you
just said you thought it was cool that
like that you're seeing that in the
media but if it's like a super feminine
woman
like who's just in her feminine or super
masculine man like I don't I would guess
you probably wouldn't have the same
reaction no I would there's a lot of
girls I listen to that they do the exact
same thing like they're twerking they're
being lit no no I said I said feminine
not twerking no but that's
um You Go I mean though like there's
feminine girls who do the same though I
don't I don't I don't think so when
they're not feminine
I I would say Feminine is typically has
like Purity
yeah so when I said earlier that you
know women create types of men that they
don't want right it's very interesting
because when I said women create the
types of men they don't want and then
that came on you're like oh yeah I love
him and I'm like yeah that's because
you're creating the types of because you
wouldn't want that type of guy as your
man would you
right but you're celebrating that a lot
of women celebrate that kind of stuff
and a lot of women push that kind of
stuff but like I said they're creating
the types of men that they don't want to
who's managed that because that's
somebody's son
someone's you know brother whatever and
I'm just saying the attacker when it
comes to the attack on masculinity I
think you know he's clearly got a beard
you know if you're trans you're trans if
you're gay you're gay if you're lesbian
lesbian but what that was to me was an
attack on the masculine image because it
it took the masculine images like a
beard bald head and it feminized it it
put a dress on it yeah that for me like
I really dislike I got like this taste
of things like that like I don't like
it's so confusing to me like if you're
going to be trans why don't you just
actually complete so you having a beard
but presenting is to me that's so
confusing it makes me uncomfortable
actually just I don't know why it's just
so weird to me I don't get it I
genuinely don't understand it like
I
can understand that because
[Music]
um
when when I see
men and they are gay but they're
feminine like they got the wig on the
whole outfit I'm like well and I've
heard people ask like well do you want
to be a woman no I don't want to be a
woman I'm just a gay man who likes to be
feminine and it's
it's confusing it's like but you you
portray this but you don't want to be
that and it's like well why don't you
just be a masculine gay dude just
because you're gay doesn't mean you have
to be feminine or
that so I can I can understand that
do you feel like the reason for so many
like effeminate men is because fathers
are not around yeah I think that a lot
of times if someone wasn't raised with a
dad I can like tell and hear it in there
they don't even have to like tell me and
like I can just kind of hear it in the
way they talk and like their voice
um and I think like typically if they're
if they're older it might be a little
bit harder but like guys in their 20s
it's like really easy to tell they
didn't grow up with a dad or a masculine
like figure around
because I I never and I had to find what
it was to be a man I literally had to go
and seek men who I thought were
masculine in some ways I
would say in my 20s like my early 20s I
was like okay cool I kind of realized
that the way I am right now isn't really
working so I need to find but because I
never had that farther figure I had to
go on a search for myself I think back
in the day a lot of people had that
before they had to to where they said I
have to find
a masculine figure and a lot of them got
it from the culture the music culture
entertainment and there was more
masculine men that were in that
um sphere in that area to where they
were able to look up to them
um whether it was rap music whether they
were on TV and it was just like the
image was more masculine nowadays
is not as much as that in your face like
this is a masculine it's like oh here's
a a trans man here's a gay man is not so
much pushing the masculine agenda but
more so the feminine isn't it more the
problem I mean I don't really I don't I
don't care if someone's gay I don't care
if someone's trans I don't really give a
monkeys like all of this stuff it's like
people you know I'm kind of Live and Let
Live Like libertarian I think people
could do what they want to do but
I think what is a bit of a problem is
that the excuse is I'm just imagining
how to say it say it no no it's just
that the uh the the poor heterosexual
man you know suffering now because
because you know now it's like for
example like Bukowski I don't know if
you guys know the writer Bukowski he's a
great he was a great writer this was a
dude who at the age who worked for the
Post Office all his life at the age of
50 gave up to to become a writer and he
was like an alcoholic he lived in Los
Angeles he would like sleep on a
mattress but he became really popular
he'd do these big readings and he'd get
all these young girls you know young
women coming to see him and he ended up
sleeping with these young women and he
wrote whole books about you know these
25 year olds that he was you know
sleeping with and everything now if you
tried to get that published Now by
mainstream publisher I guarantee you get
just thrown out of the you know you get
thrown out but those were great books
and his experience was valid right so
why can we not talk about that but we
can talk about all these other things
and I'm not necessarily denigrating the
other things either it's just that why
is one thing being pushed down to the
expense of everything else you know no I
agree and it's almost like even even
your initial reaction and it's not just
you it's like like I've caught you know
I'm sure at some point in time before I
was red pilled I had the same thing but
it's like it's like there's just certain
things in society that are like
celebrated like naturally like why are
we pushing like girls twerking why are
we pushing men in like in like Harry
Styles when he was in a dress like why
are we celebrating that more than like a
traditional family I agree you know what
I think I've come to the conclusion I
think Western culture I'd like to
celebrate negativity and I just I don't
know what it is everything about
negative or what we what goes against
the grain of the standard we just
celebrate it so like I said if it's
um seeing a video like that if it's seen
um even if you're like
like men doing crying all we celebrate
so much negativity and my friend once
told me he's like he's like Western
culture makes more money of trauma than
it does anything else so it will always
push things that are traumatic because
it will make money everything else is
like what's the point so I feel like
that's why we see it it may not be uh
more so
celebrated but it's more so gets people
talking gets people talking and it
doesn't matter what it is but if it's
like you said goes against the grain you
always you're always going to have the
group that agrees but if it's big enough
you're gonna have an even bigger group
that disagrees and either one is
generating money
yeah I think I think you that your point
earlier though I think I think there is
money to be made now in in hating on
hating on men basically and I think
that's why one of the reasons why so
many people jump on that that bandwagon
you know yep yeah I mean even with like
brand deals and stuff you get
um so much more if your audience is
women it's like that's right that's why
he's all these guys that are these
stamps pandering to like the Derek Jenks
or whatever I am so tired that man keeps
coming up on my Instagram I'm so tired
I'm surprised he's still honest yeah it
popped up I said what do you do he's
like you deserve more I'm like she's got
three kids by three different baby
daddies she deserves less
yeah it's like um was it he was
pandering to women and then he got
caught cheating yeah with like a bunch
of different girls and then one was like
a a doctor or something and got an
abortion right I I don't know that on my
part I didn't know that part did you see
the video of him with his wife Pearl oh
my gosh was it Bonnet gate yes
but then the fact that he's still around
kind of is for me is a testament to how
women are sold a dream you can sell
women anything women can know that you
are a walking red flag the man has been
cheating he's been on the Bonnet with
his woman and women are still still
engaging with this guy yeah there is a
video because they prefer this they
prefer the fantasy what did you say the
video you posted in your story oh yeah
um my baby daddy just
um I think she said skunked me three
times but I'm still going back to him
yeah they're like celebrating it and it
was just going off face off what you
said that's why I always say I'm like we
like being cheated on because why is
every girl dated a guy that cheats or at
least a guy that can cheat and it's not
it's not like a fun part of female
nature but it's pre-selection well he's
pre-selection yeah because it's like you
know women want a guy who can
theoretically get other women yeah he's
you know yeah and it's that I didn't
because when I first heard that I was
like what no we don't we don't like that
when I first like and then I was like
would you want to date a guy that no
other woman wants no no of course not
yeah
but there are like countless tick tocks
now a lot of women like saying like hang
on am I the only woman that is talking
to this guy does that mean like he ain't
got no holes oh my God I want a guy with
holes like that kind of stuff it's like
women like guys that girls like yeah I
had a friend who the mother of his child
said she liked him more when he had when
he was
potentially could cheat so when he
stopped all of it he's like something
about you just doesn't hit right with me
yeah
but that's the problem when people move
in together because when you move in you
know when you're dating or whatever and
like maybe you see her a couple of times
a week she doesn't know what you're
doing the rest of the time there's a
sort of ambiguity then you guys move in
together and then all of a sudden it's
like 24 7 and she knows what you're
doing yeah it kind of loses the Mystique
of being part of that is she knows that
she's got you unlocked yes
no I just think that I think yeah just
going what you're saying that that's
kind of spice that not knowing in your
relationship is something that can keep
a relationship alive yeah yeah but how
do you you can't keep it alive like if
you want to be married 40 50 years like
if people are gonna live to be like 100
nowadays like what are you gonna do for
the second half of your life you can't
you can't have mysteries in two separate
rooms at a house I don't know like you
that's your room this is my room how
would that work I don't know but the
problem the problems on both sides isn't
it because like it's it's like women
initiate most divorces don't they it's
not like 70 yeah we're the problem yeah
well no but
um I think women get bored you know
we're like I think men and women get
bored in in long-term relationships it's
a problem I don't really know what the
answer is but I mean even as a guy if
you're like right I'm going to keep it
in my pants I'm going to be a good boy
I'm going to be that that upright
honorable guy that I'm supposed to be
you know 15 years down the line she she
might be like oh this is a bit boring
now like I kind of fancy the pool she
calls it X yeah yeah she calls it Alpha
have you oh actually I have a question
for the guys have you ever had an ax get
married and call you or contact you
after they got married
[Music]
um
not married
I've had an ex call me after getting
into a serious relationship with their
boyfriend okay no no ring no she wasn't
married but she was like oh yeah and I
was like I thought you were like
I thought that was you now that you know
and she was a yeah but I'm sorry
yeah
listen I I do not confirm or deny
anything yeah wow I'm the same um I've
certainly had girls who were have gone
into a sort of relationships LTR serious
relationships that they've contacted not
married though um I have to be totally
transparent do you want one she was
married did she have a kid
I don't want to speak so much because
there's things happening around it oh oh
snap we're still going on
for him
all right so okay guys
masculinity because that's what we're
talking about we've spoken about the
attack I'm asking do you think
I'm gonna ask the women this as a matter
of fact do you think there's an attack
on femininity Yeah by men
no not by Men by women by women I think
yeah by women not by men in what way you
know it's it's masculine women that are
mad they're masculine and none of the
boys want them and so they're like when
when the wives come in they get mad and
they're just like
they're angry that like the wives are
wifey and it's not them and so then they
try to convince them
that femininity is bad and you're you're
living
in
like you have a horrible life you're not
really happy like when they talk about
the women from the 40s and 50s they're
like you're not really happy yeah you
could be in the streets with Ali right
when Ali said when Ali went viral there
yeah they went yeah they were I mean she
was trending on Twitter because she said
I submit to my man and I'm a housewife I
got this big ring my life is good and
then they're like well like what if he
leaves you high and dried
now the reason why I said is there
attack on femininity by men because you
know I was thinking about it is that the
trans movement
um by by biological men are now coming
into women's spaces this week
um we had in Primark there was a
incident in the changing rooms where a
man went into the female into the unisex
changing rooms unisex change rooms which
means men and women can actually go in
and a man went into the woman's cubicle
also in America
um there was a
there was a biological man who
identified as a woman who
um sexually assaulted S8 sorry somebody
within another changing room
um I've said that
women nowadays talk about patriarchy and
they talk about misogyny and I have said
the most misogynistic and patriarchal
thing that women can actually condone is
biological men coming into your private
spaces and taking them over they're
taking over your changing rooms they're
taking over your toilets they're taking
over your sports yet and still women
champion this yeah I don't think I don't
think it's an attack on femininity
honestly I think it's a cheat code for
men hmm okay what do you mean
um because you can pertain to sports you
can be a trash basketball player and all
of a sudden you say oh identify as a
woman and be
a baller because now you're into women's
sports I'm not saying that everybody
does that or anybody does that but
ultimately is it Chico if I was a man
and I was like hmm
how do I wanna get to where I want to
get to and I'm not as great as a man I
think I could be just as great or even
better as a woman and it leaves the door
open to sexual assault of course because
if you're if you're a pedo or like a
creep and now oh I get to identify as a
woman and go into the changing room
um
if I don't want to say I certainly it
sounds weird but like like if you were
in that position like that's the easiest
way to do it right exactly and it's like
I thought we were supposed to protect
women
and like and it's like they're all about
women's rights until it's the right to
our own Division and the right to our
own bathrooms and yeah and I think it's
so disrespectful with sports because I
I've trained my whole life and I'm and
I'm pretty damn good at volleyball and I
I'm I've been playing since I was in
fifth grade 10 years old and I could
maybe maybe get like two grand a month
in my housing paid for in a foreign like
like and that's and that's someone I'm
probably top two percent in terms of
skill and how far I've taken it but
there's just not a lot of opportunity so
we're gonna give the little opportunity
that we have and we spent 15 years
training for to the men what the [ __ ]
well sorry gone yeah you know what you
just said you think it's a cheat code I
think that's really interesting because
if you look at
um
traditionally
um women Industries
if you put a man in there that man
becomes so successful so let's think of
like a hairdresser if he's a man he
becomes like a really popular one and
I've never quite understood like what is
it I don't know I'm like we can't be
that much better than people who's been
doing it for all their life like so I'm
like it might be a cheat code and
certain men probably have realized yeah
I can become more successful or more
valid in this environment because I'm
going to be the man and celebrated I
guess so well for me I think
um I've always used the Captain Phillips
analogy is it Captain Phillips with Tom
Hanks and the Somali pirates and the
captain where this Somali says I'm the
captain now and it's like men are coming
into your gender saying I'm a woman now
and you just gotta take it right do you
know I mean like literal biological men
telling you as females that they can be
your gender and it's like I know as a
man that if a bunch of women started
saying they could be men I'm gonna be
like ah shut up you you can't be us
whereas women allow it well and it all
started with that freaking Caitlyn
Jenner award it did that's like that's
literally where it started and now you
have a man taking away a title from a
girl that trained her whole life to get
to that position it's like I I just I
just as an athlete I I can't even
imagine because you only get so many
shots at like a title or like something
big you don't know who's gonna compete
the next year you don't know how many
moments you're gonna have like that and
to take that away from her right yeah
and what kind of simp ass man what kind
of stuff beta ass man allowed that I I
can't even imagine like if you were the
swim coach on the other team there was a
dude coaching the freaking but that's
why I said the the week in our
government in the stronger yeah as a
dude if you allow that you should quit
before you allow that I just sorry go on
I would I would I've never I've never
heard of a I don't know
a woman who's transitioned to a man
yeah I've never heard of
someone
them winning anything
I wonder why which has got me asking how
many
um do we have numbers of how many men
are transitioning to women and vice
versa because I can only imagine is more
men transitioning to women as opposed to
the business
I would like to know what the numbers
are but why do you think that is why do
you think more so men are trans men are
saying I want to be a woman that's what
I say that's I feel like it's a cheat
code I genuinely feel like you think to
yourself like because if you think about
it if you told me
I'm gonna go prison 50 years or
something I'm not coming out yeah he
told me why would I not do that yeah why
would I not all right well two women got
pregnant in a prison even more reasons
why I should do that actually went to
went to jail yeah why would I not do
that but it's a logical sense
yeah but the thing is when I said um why
do you think it's so much that that the
men are transitioning to women I think
it's also got to do with the fact that
on some subconscious level men are being
told that their masculinity is bad and
so if my masculine is bad and I can see
that being a woman is good
but I'll I'll opt for that bit then I'll
go for the good bit because I can't be
this because being this man is bad
masculinity is bad so I think that
you're going to see more and more men
opting to be women the more and more the
attack on masculinity happens within the
society I think you're going to be
you're going to see more and more men
opting to be women join The Winning Side
I suppose yeah
do you think that
um how do I say this but the
the entertainment industry and how
um men aren't aren't
um transitioning but they are dressed up
as women for a like the thing that we
saw no so not like that so kind of like
um like Harry Styles no it's kind of
like Tyler Perry I was dressed up as a
woman like in a full-on costume but
essentially
um I drag yeah so and how people do it
on social media how they'll do a little
skit but they'll be like a woman do you
think that has an effect on masculinity
I do I mean I mean my son's 10 right and
if I saw my son on YouTube putting in a
wig as a as a little girl and trying to
be I'll be like son no no no no no no do
you know what I mean because I I think
certain things start somewhere do you
know what I mean and I think yeah I
think that whole Tyler Perry dressing up
as a woman was it art media it's just
Madea yeah a media I'm not I'm not for
it because like I said
in these days and times masculinity is
being removed I personally believe and
so anything that continues or
continuously removes a masculinity from
Men I'm just I'm just not about it wait
hold up you were shaking your head to
what you were saying but you was the
biggest champion of that video
I don't know why you guys keep on saying
I'm celebrating it and like because that
was right no I just feel like I'm not
talking about in regards to like
him promoting twerk and him being so gay
like I'm just saying like personality
wise like I've watched these interviews
I see how he moves and stuff like that
like I like him it's not a thing of I'm
promoting that he's gay even though at
the end of the day I promote people who
are so masculine I promote people who
are gay as well like I just feel like
there's no such thing as like
encouraging negative things in regards
to this video it's just like
he wants to be gay he wants to twerk he
wants to do that so why not I mean it's
not a thing of like oh my gosh yeah I
think this is why women shouldn't run
the world oh my God I don't get what you
guys mean by that book because women
because only a man like that
could be championed by a woman a man
like that wouldn't be championed by a
man the reason I would take
um what you said earlier is Be A
Champion is because you said it's so
good to see like a feminine gay guy in
the media yeah um so that to me was
championing that and like kind of
pushing it I don't think you did it
intentionally yeah I did it yeah yeah I
feel like you guys took it no no I I'm
saying the only reason I'm pointing it
out is because I think there's a lot of
subconscious things in society that we
don't really realize as women and like
once you see it you can't unsee it
um like an example this isn't
necessarily the same example but I think
of as like when we say
um a man knocked her up it's like that's
the way we subconsciously put the blame
on the man even though it takes two to
tango yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you
didn't knock yourself up whereas we
whereas we speak on this show all the
time if a woman gets pregnant it's all
on her
actually I decided to change my stance
slightly I I will give I will give men
five percent blame
I'll take I would say women 95 but like
I mean I mean yeah yeah I feel like yeah
I feel like um I used to say that it was
100 the woman's fault because we have 41
forms of birth control you can require
them when you sleep with wear a condom
you also can get an abortion I mean I
the list goes on and on and on um you
also have abstinence you also you know
go on and on where men you know they
just have condoms and even if they do
that they could steal they could be
stolen and like vasectomies but you know
that they also may not be reversible in
some cases so it's like do you really
want to risk that so because of that I
used to say a hundred percent on women
but I decided recently I was like you
know what the more I talked about some
of y'all be wild and in these streets
I'm gonna I'm gonna give you five
percent
I'm gonna say it might even be more than
that I just think that men should
protect their sperm right I think all
men should protect their sperm however
I've always said to women there's a
bunch of Reckless men out there girl oh
yeah you know there's a bunch of
Reckless men and some men aren't going
to protect their sperm and for those men
that aren't going to protect it you need
to protect yourself I'll give it
60 40. in favor of who women okay
because like as a man like
obviously as you get older
and you start to Value yourself a bit
more now I'm just like a bit of age in
my life where like you are I'm
protecting my sperm and things of that
nature so when I do that as a man it's
really hard to get anyone pregnant right
it's really hard
um
so
you have to take some accountability
because like if you if you allow if you
give 95 to the women you're leaving it
in their hands and I feel like that's
not smart I feel like it is in our hands
it is but it shouldn't be left in your
hand from a man's perspective so that's
why I say
like will you give me okay what about 30
on men 70 women yeah I'd say that okay
I'm gonna stick to five but I just want
to see if I can move you I could say
that because like you know it is it is
to see who's more to blame yeah yeah
but when you say to blame in what sense
like okay I just think women have a
complete power when it comes to
reproduction yeah like we have 41 forms
of birth control we have abortion and
especially in the UK you can get it up
to freaking six months which to me to me
yeah and it's free it's on the
government so your tax dollars are
paying for that
um on top of that we we have the choice
to give up a kid for adoption there's
cases in the U.S where the dad actually
wanted the child and the mom still gave
it up for adoption and he had no rights
in that even if we have the kid we can
get child support from the dad even if
we get married we can leave and take
half
um and I think in the UK it's between 13
and 21 wait for child support which
isn't as high in the U.S where it can be
up to 50 like 25 per kid but it's still
you're still getting a check so like no
matter what we choose we're bailed out
of every single decision and we're men
it's like the only choice you have is to
wear a condom or not wear a condom um so
when we have all this Choice like how
can I say like with more power comes
more responsibility so if we have more
power then we have to take more of the
responsibility but honestly like
some of you guys I've heard had some
guys on the show yep
some of them are wow that I'm like you
don't even you don't even pull with
girls you don't know like I'm like all
right five percent we're giveness I
remember what was the last what was the
guy's name you had Louie you had Louie
and you had drunk Justin
oh yeah and they're telling me and he
was saying that he's had like so many
he's got so many women pregnant and um
he's had like all of them had abortions
yeah I was like you know
Justin's like he's in his 20s right
isn't his 20s I believe I there's
there's someone I know that's sad
there's someone I know that said that he
wouldn't pull out with University girls
because he's like oh they have something
to lose they don't want to get pregnant
and I'm like you know what that's
actually a mindset that it makes sense
because I feel like for me not for me
the older I get the more I know like no
the women are going to keep the baby
like when you're young you're like oh my
God you don't want to get pregnant you
don't want to disappoint your parent but
as you get older you're like if you're
taking risks like that do you really
think she's gonna get rid of the child
would you really take that risk I mean
no I wouldn't to be to be fair the
numbers back it up a little bit what
he's saying women that make over forty
seven thousand dollars per year I bought
one out of three of their babies where
women below the poverty line only abort
eight percent so he's kind of right but
like do you really this is why I gave
five percent back so I was like you know
what that's that's wild Reckless so you
think that younger women are less likely
to want to have a baby is what you're
saying yeah because you're younger and
obviously you don't want to bring that
news to your parent right and then
you're still thinking about your life
and all that but as you get older and
your clocks start ticking and you're
going to start thinking well if I get
rid of it now when am I going to get
another one I thought I feel like I
always had an older friend who was like
he doesn't sleep with women with like
two or more kids because it's like but I
don't have another one but like what's
one more gonna do today
goodness it does make sense I was like
yeah that actually does make sense so
wow
it's crazy but it's like
yeah
it makes sense
I'm sorry what's my next question sorry
one second yeah I don't I don't
prescribe this I would just like to like
say now I don't I don't be careful
approval on that
um yeah this is not don't don't yeah
when it comes to respect and masculinity
um
in each everyone's life here were you
were you grown with a masculine figure
in your life that you respected
like that but also my granddad as well
my grandfather on my dad's side was a
very masculine guy he was in the World
War II he was a fighter pilot you know
he's an RAF and all that and um he was
an actually
they unfortunately my grandparents died
when they were I mean they were sort of
at 60 so quite young really but um their
relationship actually was very
the sort of the old school kind of thing
that you would people often hold back to
you know like he was very much the the
man of the house and she was you know
looking after him and doing the cooking
and all that kind of stuff so
um so yeah absolutely you know um and
you know that those that those are the
people that I looked up to so so yeah
for sure but that's going back a few
years now do you know what I mean so
were you going to a masculine figure
yeah my dad but I used to like disagree
with him so much though when I was
younger like maybe like 18 I feel like
whatever he said it just didn't sit
right with me I feel like he was he's
very very traditional though so
obviously I'm Nigerian so we go back to
Nigerian culture of like the leadership
dictatorship of men in general and I
just didn't like the way dictatorship
dig what I'm joking but yeah yeah I mean
I just feel like
um I didn't like the way he would
speak to my mom also and the way he
would like
kind of order her around I see my mom
submissive as well to my father so I'll
just look at him like why would like my
mom I would look at my mom like why
would you do these things for him that's
when I was like 18 but now I'm starting
to understand it a bit more in regards
to like making the female a bit more
feminine like being a bit more
submissive but I just feel like
I don't want to argue again but I just
feel like in general men need to
understand and learn how to speak to
females they want to appreciate yeah I
mean I think women we don't even know
how we like to be spoken to right and
and this is you know a very a very again
once you see it you can't unsee it women
like toxic
we like it and it's not it's like this
is this is what girls this is what girls
say and then and then they all have a
toxic ax it's like okay if you don't
like toxic why are you sleeping with
toxic
I don't know you personally so I don't
know I don't know what you're doing yeah
but it's like there's certain behaviors
that are attractive to women it's like
there's a difference between arousal and
attraction so arousal is like like the
bad boy and attraction is like the guy
you want to take home to Mom and like
every girl wants the perfect mix of both
but a lot of times they don't exist as a
man ever spoke to you and you're like oh
um what do you mean what did you mean
you liked it and he was very Stern with
you have you as a woman not thought oh
my God that I don't know why I liked
that but I liked that depending on the
context I feel like like if it's hey
let's not get personal but
no not like that common I feel like it
just depends on the context if it's just
like
point out rude for no reason I'll just
be like don't talk to me like that but
if it's a thing of like I'm indecisive
maybe yeah I mean and he's just like no
we're just going to do it like this I'll
be like okay but when you say don't
speak to me like that like you said
earlier on that you used to watch you
used to think that about your dad that's
what I'm saying it was when I was
younger where's that where's that kind
of rebelliousness come from
in when it when masculine Authority
shows itself like where do you think
that rebelliousness came from I just
don't think his masculine Authority
though like I feel like you can be
masculine and still speak to females
nicely like I don't know I don't know
do you do you think the CEO of a Fortune
500 company is making sure he talks to
his employees nicely or the Commander in
a war probably not but he probably has
to now because of HR but
for the feelings yeah yeah like like
part of masculinity is just like that
get [ __ ] done
regardless yeah regardless of how you
feel like like instead of oh honey do
you want to do this nah do this do this
get that done well a lot of a lot of
what we teach like the way you say like
just demanding it like it's just a
certain I don't know a lot of a lot of
what we teach in the say the earlier
stages like the the chatting out phase
before it gets into a relationship you
know we we teach guys to be basically
like less less conventionally nice in a
way because like most people contrary to
popular belief you know most people that
struggle with um well I think probably
most the majority of guys really are
actually kind of nice guys or at least
they've they've been conditioned to be
nice guys and that comes through the way
they're talking so you know go up to the
guys you know be having a conversation
with like a nodding dog like oh yeah you
know so what'd you do I work at
McDonald's oh really oh wow that's so
cool you know and it's like it's
obviously it's not cool you know
um but he's just saying that to sort of
count out her to placate her whatever
right so we say to guys look don't you
know just stop doing that stop being
just massively impressed by everything
she says stop being so damn agreeable if
she says something that you disagree
with say that you disagree with it right
you don't have to go along with
everything you know doing those simple
things and it really does change up the
dynamic and it's not about being just a
complete you know like dick where you're
you're just insulting her because
because like like you said I mean you
can't go too far with it as well if you
go in and you're just like you say
something just ridiculously rude
obviously she's going to tell you where
to go because yeah but there's a way of
doing it where you're just not being
this complete pushover and obviously
fake kind of nice dude just for the sake
of it you know yeah to touch on what you
said um
yeah I don't I don't think women I don't
think women like
necessarily be spoken nice to you and I
say that simply
because when I was out here trying to
get women
I I intentionally was just outlandishly
rude and it just worked for me it just
was what every time you try to be nice
it just it doesn't work so actually just
girls
across the board not not obviously not
obviously over the top like I just knew
if I was
but I gave you too much compliment I
always threw a compliment with a slight
hint of like I don't really like that
though like so I'll compliment this but
I won't compliment that and something
like that and it just seemed to work for
me and I just started recognize there's
a pattern in like women respond so much
in this way but I'm trying I'm sure
you're old enough to know this you know
the same treating me what I mean it's
real it's real treat and mean to keep
them Keen wow yeah that's what we said I
mean keep them key and the other thing
is nice guys finish loss right yeah
there's a reason why they say that right
there's a reason why they say that yeah
but to answer your question in terms of
um did I grow up with a masculine man
I think
not necessarily
in what I got from let's say my dad at
least at that age whether I understood
it or not was he was doing what he
needed to do
for his partner right at that time I I
didn't think anything with it masculine
or not
um at the age of nine I stopped growing
up with him and so I didn't know what
the relationship looked like what was
that however as I get older
I look back at most of the men and I
respect them more as I get older and so
I'm like oh even though I made a full
negative of you or or let's say for
example in the case of oh someone's just
being really harsh or as I get older and
recognize people only move when you put
your foot down otherwise they're not
doing nothing right and everything
starts to make sense to me like oh I
understand why he was like this I
understand why you did this I understand
what you did it all made sense like as
as I get older in life and this is
something I hope to teach my son because
he's at an age where he feels like being
nice is and I'm trying to get him out of
that you know in a sensible way of
teaching him like listen it's good to be
nice but you're gonna have to be
ruthless in this world because no one
don't listen to nothing I think my son
said I'm teaching the same thing yeah
and a woman complimented me the other
day and I think is one of the best
compliments I ever received she said
you're a good person with a bad boy
spirit and I was like I like that
that's what you need though really
that's what you want it's that nice bad
boy thing yeah like you know you're
fundamentally you're a you're a decent
guy you know she can feel safe with safe
with you but you're not predictable
you're not you're not a pushover you
know and you've got a bit of edge to you
that's the key thing I think I actually
didn't I actually done it um uh podcast
with a woman called ZZ Mills over here
right and she was saying she was saying
as a woman that you know women do like a
guy with an edge you know she was saying
that you know the guys that are I guess
Square the guys that are normal yeah
they don't really get much play and you
know we speak about the 80 of men all
the time on this show and how 80 of the
men are generally just normal average
dudes they don't cut a shape when they
walk in the room yes right they they're
the guys that you walk past on the
street that are doing the the bins or
they're at Starbucks or the ones working
on the tour and women generally because
of this I've always had hypergamy on
steroids right now
um they don't tend to look at those guys
yes as very masculine and they don't
tend to gravitate towards those guys
yeah yeah definitely well me and James
Tusk are currently and this isn't a plug
because it's closed but we're currently
teaching a course called The Edge
yeah we plug here all right guys come on
if you want to join the
edgefrancis.com but no me me and James
doesn't got this course we'll probably
well we we're going to talk about that
further down the line but anyway
um and it is to try to teach this side
of things because it because guys will
be like okay right so I've got to go and
approach girls I've got to go chat up
girls and if they could get the courage
together to do that which is you know
you'll take it down to about five
percent of all men who are like our [ __ ]
right I bet Starbucks is a cute girl
I'll actually go and have a conversation
with her right the guys that get through
to that stage and actually do that then
most of them are just being too too
beige too bland two vanilla and it comes
through everything like how you dress
the way you present yourself your body
language like all of these different
things and it's like you've got to I
mean if you look at people like um if
you look at the classic people like the
tides you look at like Justin Waller and
you know
like like some of some of these figures
I mean yes you know you could say Well
they're quite they're good looking what
are the Jacks whatever but it's sort of
more than that they've got that attitude
haven't they yeah do you know what I'm
saying and I think like a good at that
attitude on a guy adds like two three
point like yeah it does a lot
it um but yeah like there's nothing like
just that yeah there's there's nothing
like a guy that's like very confident
it's the borderline cocky well people
say say with the Tates for example
people will say with the tights well
yeah but you know they got money and
before the the apocalypse you know they
had these massive Instagram accounts
they got these Lambos and all these sort
of stuff you know no wonder it's easy
for them but you know you could just
tell and I mean Andrew will say I was
getting action before I was famous
before I was rich and you could just
tell me you could see that do you know
what I mean because they've got that
thing and you know and and most guys
haven't that's the problem I don't even
remember when we when you went into the
Big Brother house right yeah yeah and
yeah he was on Big Brother oh wow Andrew
Tate was on big brother and I remember
him from the Big Brother house and one
of the first things on the Big Brother
house is that he came in and he went in
and was like yeah eight of you in here
are snakes
and everyone's like what who the [ __ ] is
you do you know what I mean your snake
you're a snake you're a snake and
they're like listen we don't even know
you just came in and this is the first
thing he said yeah because I've been
watching from the outside and he just
came in and you were like who the hell
is that guy and is that and it's that
type of presence you can tell he's been
like that for a very long time yeah well
he was born he was born in America moved
to Luton
stayed in Luton for for a long time
which is why his accent sounds yeah and
then he went back to America um then now
he's in um where is he living now uh
Romania Romania yeah yeah so yeah is
that like you said that confidence that
men exude that masculine confidence that
men exude and it has to sit on the
borderline of being slightly rude or
like just a bit arrogant yes there's a
level of arrogance you need to have well
if you look at the dark tried
personality types or psycho psychopathy
narcissism and machiavellianism which is
you know basically being a bit sneaky
doing whatever it takes to get what you
want no psychopathy we we tend to Define
this sort of like reduced empathy like
you just don't care that much whatever
people think right
um and narcissism obviously you know you
think very highly of yourself and people
with those three traits interlinked it's
it's been shown in studies that they
tend to get better results in dating in
related sexual relationships but also in
the workplace you know a lot of CEOs and
those people that have these traits in
very high index so you know it's may not
be pretty but this stuff works most
definitely
well super chats again yeah and then
round up and then we'll get final
thoughts and stuff yeah of course
um okay so guys make sure you like the
video that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out our
content so
the loud and strong podcast tutor like
dirt she'll stick to you like mud Aaron
deep truth men are the ones who create
life women carry it but only when
activated by men in our sperm Sarah is
right men protect your seed this old
lady I love my benefit oh my gosh
what's that word benevolent benevolent I
was like I can't remember how to say it
vanilla
I don't wanna I love my dictator
I'm I'm well I'm beyond cared for ladies
your power lies and your femininity ask
any good man hell ask any Man mgtow by
Logic your mom wasn't submissive she was
afraid submission is a result of
authentic desire chasing leadership not
fear Lawrence men have civilized the
world so much that the same women
believe there's no difference between
the Sexes and they say anything a man
can do mgtail by Logic some women let
other women and feminist men destroy
masculinity men can't fix it we're
destroyed women have to fix it and they
won't because they don't like to lead so
things only get worse Chris fegley
Boy Scouts started by Baden Powell in
the UK to teach boys to be disciplined
young men now allows girls because girls
wanted to do what boys could do they can
choose to do the same stuff in Girl
Scouts still low-key 21. how did that
gay dude from the video not get canceled
he made a diss song about a man in a
wheelchair that went viral called walk
what the f map butcher big entities are
now normalizing alternative Lifestyles
to indoctrinate kid kids long games same
in politics they know what they are
doing and it's working the psych and
behavioral conditioning is Deep mgtel by
Logic sorry Pearl but equality in
volleyball demands it this is a woman's
problem to solve too men can't do it
because we're monsters sunshine in La
for 20. I'm bored in putting up numbers
but do you all think I need to go back
in slaying in order to attach the dime
Peach I really want keep up the good
work
Damien Wade what what does the Awakening
of the West say about how we are
perceived by the Soviet Union China
middle Eastern patriarchal governments
mgtow by Logic turns out women are just
effective men Alistair Horton most women
want a man who has the power to cheat
just doesn't use it Darris fry just
supporting the channel
Samantha Ricky Martin is a masculine gay
man
um via Joker's a modern women being too
modern and man being too feminine is
killing human numbers on Earth big facts
mgtow logic LOL she's so bad at
recognizing femininity she can't even
see that 99.99 of gay men are portrayed
as feminine women are so lost Sloan
Fidel this is a cute conversation and
and I admire you Pearl for fighting in a
feminine way for the truth but the West
is finished marriage is finished men and
women are finished as genders so so just
play the piano when the Titanic plunges
Carlos and Velez shout out to my wife um
Raquel Melendez love you girl
um Matt butchered
Matt butcher the attack is real do you
see the same against women this is
exactly why Free Speech encounter
narratives like this show and others are
so important mgtow by Logic pick me
girls get picked hoes be mad about it
LOL Dustin Denton I desire to find a
woman I can never own but she wants or
desires to be owned by me it's all the
super chats wow all righty uh ladies and
gents thanks for coming um what I'm
gonna do or what we're going to do
um is just get your final thoughts on
the subject before we go yeah and you
can plug any social media yeah plug any
social let people know where you're
going where you're at
Joy
is there an attack on masculinity uh yes
probably I'm still uncertain the degree
to which it's driven by commercial
requirements and the degree to which
it's actually right we want to put men
down because I do think that most most
consumers are female and a lot of these
sort of big companies are sort of
pandering to that to some extent they're
thinking we don't want to lose our
Revenue because if we if we upset the
women then that's going to cause US
problems but look I mean clearly I think
in the West in the anglosphere
we've got this big sort of sort of
cultural War type situation going on now
whereby you know hurting people's
feelings is verboten you can't really
say anything it's very very difficult
and I think that's a terrible terrible
shame and I think the worst thing about
it for me is that it's now impacting on
into relationships between human beings
you know like now going up and having a
conversation with someone in a coffee
shop could be seen as being like a a
toxic act which I think is a terrible
thing because I I think we should just
come together you know men and women are
better together than apart and um you
know we should celebrate just normal
basic human interactions
um anyway if you want to find me then my
YouTube channel is just type in Troy
Francis you'll find my channel uh you
can find me on Twitter at real Troy
Francis on Instagram at real Troy
Francis as well and yeah if anyone wants
to talk about their their dating life
and get some solutions for that you can
jump on a call with me go to any of my
socials and you'll see a link to do to
get to get an appointment in my calendar
to do a free call yeah guys Troy is the
real deal we're big fans of his channel
here um
a lot of times
um you know there are times when we're
not very solution oriented but I think
what you provide on your channel is very
solution oriented and we appreciate that
thank you very much I appreciate it
um
do I believe masculinity is attacked
um I'm just going to be blunt with it
I'm not really too bothered but I just
feel like maybe it is but I also think
femininity is attacked as well I just
feel like the whole subject is just
subjective as it is and it's just gonna
go in loops and Loops until we all die
that's how that's how I feel
um my socials is
on everything
on YouTube an idiot 5K let's try and get
there oh yeah what you do on your
Channel
I can't even describe it everything like
I do discussions I do hauls like makeup
I do everything okay so it just depends
yeah it's like a lifestyle type Channel
yeah entertainment I would say but yeah
that's me okay
um is masculinity under attack
now having this conversation a lean to
the yes
but more so with what Trey was saying I
feel like maybe if men became the bigger
consumer of things we can tip the scale
because now they have to cater to us
maybe
um so yeah in that sense
um what else is it what else would you
say so or they can find you oh wait they
can find me oh mate in these streets
I guess you could find me on Instagram
rebound Rubik's r-u-b-e-n-r-u-b-i-x
um try not to find me though but yeah
[Laughter]
um my my final thoughts
um
yeah just men be masculine women be
feminine all right if it was that easy
then it would be that way but I do think
that there is an attack on masculinity
um
and so like lifting being talking more
about feminine
femininity and all that comes with that
is more more so like muting masculinity
from my thoughts
um you can find me on Instagram and
YouTube at your girl justly can I ask
for a question
um
um you work in a date you know things of
that nature like what is your prediction
of what's gonna happen like later on in
the future the future great question the
chat apocalypse the Chads are taking
over and it's unless you're seven foot
tall and you've got a 12 pack then
you're you're not going to get anything
yeah
um no that's think on a serious note I
think dating has become a lot harder and
I think
um social media's got a big part of
playing that Instagram the dating apps
etc for various reasons you know
um the Market's been opened up we've got
this almost Global sexual market now
where a girl in city in Lithuania can
you know theoretically gets shipped over
to a fancy private yacht in Miami or
something so you know there's this big
competition that's going on that didn't
exist before
um I think the solution for I mean I
think long term who who can say really I
think the solution but I think right now
the solution is in individual guys hands
do you know what I mean because actually
if you learn some social skills and you
get out of the house and you even in
your own country your own City travel
around a bit but certainly if you could
travel outside of your country go to
some different cool spots there's
definitely some great dating
relationship experiences to be had still
so long-term prognosis may not be so
good but I think right now there's a
world of opportunity out there one more
question oh sorry you
um seeing as you're doing this thing and
you're obviously becoming more popular
and busy Etc she's bombing the internet
right now I love consider yourself for
feminine women interesting
um I would say
um
and if if you do or don't
whatever it falls under if you had a man
who is masculine or
and he told you all right pal no more
YouTubers
um one to ten on feminine I'd give
myself
five six I think I I was a bit of a
tomboy growing up so I think that's kind
of like hard for me but I was raised by
a wife so I think that helps
yeah I am starting wife school soon
shout out shout out High School
um honestly
it's a lot this can be stressful if a
guy wanted to take it off my hands I I
would prefer to like maybe build
something like together you know like
maybe if he had like a channel like I
could help him with his and do something
together
um because I think it'd kind of be a
waste you know like if you have a
profitable but I don't know why you
would want but honestly it can be really
stressful so yeah I would
cool
my final thoughts are you can find me at
saragavi on all social medias and um in
closing I'd just like to say that
if you have watched
oh you haven't watched two or more of
our videos tell them
and you have not subscribed tell them
then we have what beef what do we got
Pearl beef exactly so you better get
doing that right now if you haven't done
it
hello
okay guys make sure you like the video
on your way out a like is free
um I know a bunch of you don't subscribe
I see the analytics
um but thank you for 400k
um don't forget to leave a comment let
me know your thoughts
um like the video subscribe to our Clips
Channel Sign up for our memberships
first tier gets you in the chat second
tier gets you to see our Vlogs and our
Discord third tier gets to connect with
us on social media and fourth fourth
tier is a one-on-one call with me once a
month I've gotten so many people to like
10 20K 30k with my coaching I
there are people with 100K that will
tell you it is because of the stuff that
I have told I have told them so nice
like literally that that is the most
value that you will get for 500 bucks a
month nice um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way out and we will talk to you next
time
[Music]